le ballon était à l'honneur à guyancourt
pour la vingtième année consécutive le
club local organisé ce samedi 5 janvier
son traditionnel tournoi de futsal au
gymnase de l'aviation ça permet au club
de fêter la nouvelle année avec tous les
plus jeunes du club
réunir tous les éducateurs et les
dirigeants au total ont rendez-vous
attiré 230 joueurs du club de la
catégorie des moins de 6 ans à celle des
moins de 13 ans objectif les tester dans
des conditions inédites là en fait qu'on
recherche c'est surtout le jeu d'abord
de pouvoir jouer en salle ce qu'on n'a
pas on n'a jamais l'occasion dans la
dans l'année de de participer au grand
gymnase et puis ça nous permet aussi la
dans le cadre de ce tournoi de jouer
avec différentes catégories
pendant la journée deux tournois 5
contre 50 étaient organisées dans le
gymnase chaque équipe était composée de
footballeurs de catégorie d'âge
différentes
le but équilibrer le jeu et surtout
créer du lien entre les participants ça
va changer
depuis ça se connaître
aidons
et de plus à s'améliorer et et et de et
de participer avec des gens qu'on
connaît pas pour
essayez d'être avec des équipes pour te
en
pour l'enfant le club de guillon
qu'organisera nouveau tournant en juin
mais cette fois ci sur une pelouse en
extérieur
[Musique]